peut-on définir l'identité noire ça
c'est la grosse question alors je ne
sais pas si l'identité noire peut être
défini mais je pense qu'on peut prendre
l'expression plurielle et parlé d
identité noire
quand on parle de la catégorie noir on
parle d'une catégorie raciale qui est
apparue en tout cas dans le monde
occidental un moment précis de
l'histoire qui est lié à l'histoire
notamment de la traite négrière et du
colonialisme et à partir de sept de ces
moments précis de l'histoire avec la
dispersion des populations d'origine
africaine on a eu cette construction qui
a donné lieu aux identités noir et à
l'identité blanche que là je garderai au
singulier donc les identités noir se
sont toutes les identités qui ont été
produites à l'intérieur du continent
africain mais aussi à l'extérieur et qui
sont des identités qui ont été
construites comme inférieures
mais qui en dépit de cette infériorité
décrété et imposer ont tout simplement
produit des trésors de l'humanité donc
quand on pense à l'identité noire
on pense à cette identité de résistance
on pense à la musique on pense je sais
pas tout ce qui est lié aux textiles aux
vêtements on pense à toutes les langues
on pense aux littératures les armes jeu
voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai eu
d'écrire et l'identité noire c'est une
identité de résistance une identité qui
au départ a été bafouée et qui
finalement a toujours essayé de garder
un degré de dignité et à degré de un
degré de fierté
au moment